[Musique]
le chèque numérique
il a été créé en fin 2018 pour aider les
commerçants à ceux numérisés et à être
plus compétitifs notamment par rapport à
tout commerce en ligne et les grandes
surfaces peut être de la création d'un
site internet de la publicité digitale
s'appelle des abonnements à des
marketplace de la formation au numérique
comme je le disais puisqu'on l'a étendu
pendant le premier confinement ça peut
être également des frais de livraison
donc voilà c'est assez vaste et on
s'adapte au fur et à mesure des besoins
que nous remonter à la fois les
commerçants et les restaurateurs
notamment
il faut se rendre sur le site de la
région et donc il ya ce chèque numérique
que vous trouverez donc vous pouvez
candidate et après fournir les factures
et toucher un maximum de 1500 euros faut
savoir que ça ne finance pas 100 % des
dépenses ça c'est les financements
publics
on va jusqu'à 50 % des dépenses là on
voit d'ailleurs un intérêt pour ce
dispositif puisque on a dix fois plus de
demandes au quotidien que par rapport à
avant pour les communes qui voudrait
lancer un moment de mouvements un peu
plus vaste pour au sein de leur ville
pour tous leurs commerçants ont créé des
marques et de plex local nous à la
région valérie pécresse on les
accompagne par le volet 2 du chèque
numérique qu'on a lancé récemment qui va
jusqu'à 10000 euros sachant qu'une
plateforme locale comme ça de vente au
niveau d'une commune ça coûte entre 20
et 40